was uns wirklich große sorge macht ist
die entwicklung und das ist auch die
große unbekannte
wie weit wird sich ein mutiertes virus
entwickeln die zahlen in england und
irland sind besorgniserregend und der
anstieg in niederlande der damit
zusammen hängt eben auch weil es eine
ist auf den inseln das andere ist auf
dem continental bereich und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es sich stärker
ausbreitet ist jedenfalls nach allen
erfahrungen die man hat nicht gering
auch in deutschland auch in bayern
wurden die fälle bislang nachgewiesen
wobei wir keinen ernsthaften
zwischenstand darüber haben weil wir nur
in berlin bislang eine sogenannte
sequenzierung stelle haben die genau
diesen speziellen schnelleren und
aggressivere variante nachweisen kann
was ist das problem an der mutation es
positive könnte sein der impfstoff wird
wohl da auch wirken das ist glaube ich
die hoffnung damit verbunden ist das
negative eindeutig aggressive revieren
verbreitung setzt sich in der in der
dominanz eines virus durch
hinzu kommt dass er wohl so sind die
aussagen der experten bis zu 170 fach
schnellere verbreitung hat dh die
natürlichen aha regeln die wir haben mit
dementsprechend abstand könnten deutlich
zu wenig sein und insbesondere in den
ländern die jetzt sehr stark betroffen
war dort schule und kita bei jungen
leuten ein echter pandemie beschleuniger
insofern müssen wir das ganze extrem
ernst nehmen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren